Matt Negi Chicago Bears head coach back
here in the Rich Eisen show how are you
sir I'm better for talking to you I know
you've been talking to a lot of people
today across the radio dials and
television dials everywhere what's the
most obvious question that you got asked
today coach um well we're getting these
questions on how we're handling these
these zoom calls and then I'm getting
questions on which I'm supposing the
same from you in regards to the whole
Stravinsky competition is there
something going on there something up
with that I just know this much I know
this I told you last year that we were
gonna get a special play in just named
after you and I never got to that point
man though you know we we got to be a
little better this year a lot better
actually and so we we got to keep that
thing that's got to happen this year see
you're trying to throw me off the scent
by by by catering to my ego coach and
I'll let you know I appreciate that
number one number two as you know I try
to make life better for you always I try
to make life better for you I was
concerned that you like a fellow
follically challenged man keep going out
there with a visor on cold days
genuinely concerned for you concerned
about the sunscreen use it you would use
you know wear a hat you wear a visor did
you have you have you thought twice
about that coach I thought for twice for
about two seconds and I said no I'm just
gonna I'm sticking to it
man I'm I'm gonna stick with that visor
and then um I'm not changing you are who
you are you know you will know who I am
that's right you only know one speed
okay so you call it a competition I
heard you use that word what does it
kind what how does a competition look to
you well going on right now all right
ease meeting but when we get going
whenever that is
I think what's been really good and is
the fact of our coach is talking through
how we're going to go about with reps
creating you know ways to evaluate both
these guys they've been really good and
and the discussions that we're having
just learned and learning to the things
that we're keeping in our office the
things that we're not keeping and you
know obviously nick has a history with
us and in Philadelphia as a as a rookie
and then in Kansas City as a back up
there that to Alex Smith and and then
obviously other coaches too that are on
our staff but it's been coach flips done
a really good job coach laser of really
keeping things going in that room that
we have and you know when we get out to
the training camp whenever that is or
these these uh these OTAs they'll be
rocking and rolling so is the
competition right now as to who's
quickest to start their audio with video
on the zoom is that part of the
competition right now between though
ever hit the spacebar faster they go to
get off of mute and talk about you we
you know what it's got to start
somewhere
yeah so but let me ask you the question
I hear all the time and I wonder what
your answer is to it and it's the simple
question of what happened to Mitchell
true Biscay last year and I know that
that is rife with a ton of negativity
but we're talking about a guy who was a
playoff quarterback the year of the year
before and you were coach of the year
and then last year looked nothing like
the year before and I wonder what your
answer and assessment is of the question
I get from fans all the time on the
circuit again in these situations when
you go from winning the division of 2018
that twelve and four and then you go to
eight mate and you lose four games in
last year you lose four games in a row
and the offense is really struggling and
things aren't going the way you want
them to go one thing that that we all
understand in the sports were all
especially in the NFL is that you know
there's only one quarterback and and so
that comes with the territory that we
all understand that that's when you when
you win you're going to get a lot of
praise that you probably shouldn't get
and when you lose it's the same way so
that said we all understand that I
understand that as a head coach we
understand that as a team we we know
offensively there's a lot of that you
know the magnifying glasses is on us
because we didn't score enough points
that's what it comes down to is you have
to score touchdowns you got to score
points you got to be efficient in the
red zone
you you need to win that's how
quarterbacks are evaluated and you know
mention the last two years he's 19 and
10 as a starter and and so the
quote-unquote expectations you know the
standards that we have we didn't reach
him last year but there's more reasons
than then than just the quarterback now
where mich can get better and he knows
this and that's why I can say it is we
talked about the whole you know next
play mentality just being able to
continue to whenever it's a if there's a
bad play that happens have the next play
be a good play if it's a good play that
happens let's have the next play be a
better play and so he's really there's
time in the last this past year where he
showed that and so he's going to keep
growing now that said you know obviously
we brought in Nick and and Nick has been
at the top he's been at the bottom of
the valley and so now you have word
declaring as a healthy QB competition
and these guys are very very competitive
and it's going to be interesting to see
you know how it ends up going but I
really think that for going back to your
question with Mitch that he's gonna
welcome this challenge and and that he
knows too it's only in fairness that
there we could have been better in a lot
of different areas including myself last
year as an office so I look in term and
also in terms of human beings who's
gonna make the what could be an awkward
situation not so much in that room you
couldn't have a better human being than
Nick Foles all that said coach Matt Negi
here in the Rich Eisen show if the
quarterback and Travis Keys issue was
among other things if a team game
understood that he had issues with
adversity happening and being able to
turn the page how will he handle another
person being brought in for his job yeah
well that'll be that'll be the big
question and I think all he can do and
the discussions that we've had is is you
can only control your opportunity that
you have right now you know control you
can control and so he's gotten to this
point through a lot of hard work and and
and now I mean the way that he has been
just you know in these meetings that
we've had discussions that we've had I
absolutely love his attitude I don't
think you could have handled the
situation any better I mean you look at
a guy that in our situation where we
went ahead and made a trade for Nick and
and then we you know we're now at a
point where as any any person that when
that happens naturally you're going to
you know you're just going to feel like
okay how do I make this better and for
probably a day or two he was that way
after that now ever since he's been
really really good and I appreciate that
about now we're gonna we're gonna go out
there and whenever it is next and OTAs
or training camp go out there and
compete that's going to it's going to be
so good for the Chicago Bears that we
have two really good people like you
said with Nick and with Mitch in a small
room trying to make the Bears the best
team we can be offensively and as
leaders and and they're both gonna help
each other out and in the end we hope it
helps us out I have about three minutes
left for you uh before my my heart out
as they say in the television and radio
business coach Matt negiah the Bears the
vote on the 4th and 15 play that would
be an option for you as opposed to an
onside kicked you like that would you
vote for it yay again I for me I know
I'm on the line with it but I really
whatever they say I'm cool with I think
that what you have to do is if it is for
1415 you got to start having some some
plays they're gonna give you the best
opportunity possible because again the
onside kick is such an intriguing week
if you look at us go back last year we
actually had some good success with
onside kick so I'm good either way I
love opportunities of 14 15 but shoot
our coach Taber has done a great job
with our special teams in the last last
couple of years so I'm good with that
I'm what about just doing the math and
maybe attempting it to steal a
possession you're up would you do
something like that
you could I mean it's I don't know I I
have to study it more I know it's it's
definitely unique and and I like that
part about it but there's depth there's
going to be some questions that that
don't bring out to us and tell us you
know the way things that you can do and
things that you can't do and I'm real
excited to see what they say my coach
really appreciate the time thanks for
for joining you can't see but I do have
the visor that you sent I'm wearing it
right now I love and I'm pleased to say
even though I think the show it's been
doing real well since you sent it to me
my head size is the same hasn't gotten
any bigger it still fits so it's cool
that it works that that's very important
but you know I appreciate your support
and you do a heck of a job with all this
stuff I hope you and your family are
saying thank you healthy and safe and
everything and preciate it I appreciate
it but again the the the visor are just
only accentuates the follically
challenged part of the lid I just need a
channel to channel my inner Matt Negi
and just roll with it hey just be you
man be you
okay be you I said hey I see that on
your I see that on your play sheet all
the time still out there coach thanks
for the call appreciate it
you go that's Matt [ __ ] hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here